please turn your attention to the field
and welcome back two-time all-star
and 2019 world series champion
john
well folks you know well max features a
fastball 95 to 97 miles per hour great
slider great change up
max goes full count
first batter of the game swing i'm gonna
miss on 95. looked like it had some
cutting action away
max's third of the national league
77
strikeouts
now nicholas castigano's one ball and
two strikes
swing and a miss on the scherzer slider
he pulls out every part of the
repertoire in a one two three first
inning he'll take on tyler malley 54 k's
in 45 innings it's trey turner to lead
things off it's the pitch and turner
going to a knee pops one up on the
infield right in the middle near second
base kyle farmer on the infield grass
will make the catch for out number one
here's tyler naquin the center fielder
now scherzer over the head they'll wind
the kick in the pitch swing and a miss
struck him out with a cutter make one
caught fish in here tyler stevenson
here's the wide of the 1-2 swing and a
miss struck him out with a change up
four strikeouts for max scherzer
including the last three
cincinnati reds going down swinging top
of the third inning and scherzer will go
to work here against kyle farmer first
pitch swinging fly ball into left and
it's hit deep and it is gone one nothing
rep oh cow farmer first pitch fastball
and he let it rip and rip it did right
over the left field wall and the reds
are on the board first well the pitch
was on the inner half but it was right
in the middle of the zone
and farmer wasting no time
3-2 this will be an interesting
selection for max scherzer
riding high with the heater
and that's number five
andrew stevenson leads off two strike
count barnhart on the outside corner and
it's popped up into left field winker
will have this one when it comes down
and there's one down for max scherzer
top of the order here's trey turner
here's a ground ball right to farmer
this time
and they will throw out turner for the
final out here in the third through
three reds one nationals none nick
castellanos the wine of the pitch
swing a long drive to left this one
toward left center deep schwarber not
going to get it and it is one hop off
the wall schwarber is unable to glove
the carrum castiano's rounds second he's
going to go to third schwarber's throw
is cut off by turner
so that may be a double and an error
schwarber mishandled the carrum off the
wall trying to glove it
and off this glove and dropped at his
feet
and so castiano's takes an extra 90 feet
the batter is tyler naked the 1-2
nothing fancy
swinging in the miss
strikeout number six naquin twice
two down here in the fourth
well max just buckled down and stuck
with the heater here's stevenson jubal's
two strikes castiano's off third max
kicks fires swinging a miss blew him
away 96 to the outside
strikeout number seven for scherzer and
he took it up a level bottom of the
fourth and ants are still looking for
their first base hit juan soto leads off
the o2 pitch
and strike three trying to check appeal
he went
second k from ali so here's josh bell
with one out
bell
and then answer on the scoreboard with
the base hit at least
on a ball very well hit to the left of
second base this is a bullet by josh
bell in the left field and as i said
before
y'all gotta just stay on the fastball
turn around at 95.96 runners on first
and second and one out and bring up the
pitcher tyler malley
swinging away
the risk you take as a manager david
bell turned him loose and it's a 5-3
double play one out here at the bottom
of the fifth inning
swinging a line drive in the left that's
gonna fall in a base hit for john gomes
off a slider winker to his right toward
the lineup with her to get it back into
the nationals have their second hit of
the game andrew stevenson fly to left
his only time up
oh what a pick at first by stevenson
our stevenson beats the relay
i thought he might go to the bag and tag
it first
and then set up the tag play at second
but they tried to go the long way there
but that's a big second out because now
you get scherzer
and scherzer pounds it into the ground
two big hops to farmer he fields and
throws him out the inning is over so
o'malley gets the job done in the end
the national strand one we've played
five
deuterosuares who was struck out twice
the pitch and suarez swings he drives
one high in the air deep right did he
get it soto back and gone
suarez drives one out of here to the
opposite field deep right center field
two nothing reds
suarez with his 10th home run of the
year
slowed the body down a little bit a
little more quiet step with that front
foot instead of so aggressive stays back
long enough and he crushes that one
looks like a double switch will be
employed anton coming out of the bullpen
for the 15th time
first pitch to india
feed to farmer
on the first double play antone on one
pitch
gets the job done top of the seventh
inning reds lead two to nothing it'll be
tucker barnhart here's the one two swing
and a miss struck him out with a cutter
and that is strikeout number nine
for max scherzer first played appearance
for alex blandino one ball two strikes
max delivers
slider in the dirt the runner caught off
he's breaking for second to throw down
there and harrison has it chasing him
toward first punk fakes two throws and
then gets the tag
runner out of the baseline anyway as
farmer runs himself right out of the
inning here's juan der suerro
blandino was at the plate
swag
93
with life
10th strikeout
by the nats staff tonight hey eugenio
suarez this will be a 2-2 to suaren
this bat went around that's a strikeout
couldn't stop his body or the bat two
down
runners on first and second nobody out
scott heinemann 28 year old outfielder
now the left-hander delivers swinging a
chopping ground ball toward the middle
turner has it he flips to harrison throw
to first in time
another double play turned by the
nationals
over to third goes castiano's get the
left-handed catcher here tucker barnhart
swaying and a miss the nats have one
more chance so here's josh bell
and another long count from garrett
and this one lifted deep left center
see
you
later
josh bell
some right-handed power
and the gnats are on the board
[Applause]
what a great at-bat there from josh bell
got a call back schwarber and here is
zimmerman
[Applause]
grounded
suarez
the reds aren't out away nobody on two
outs lucas sims coming in one out to get
to nail this baby down one 1-2 pitch
grounded to suarez
he makes the throw ball game red
cincinnati claims the opener